when we stand on a bathroom scale we
learn for better or worse our weight
in more precise terms the scale
quantifies our mass
all matter in the visible universe has
mass
it's what governs the movement of
planets stars and galaxies through the
force of gravity
and all matter everywhere is structured
in the same way
the standard model of physics developed
more than 50 years ago explains this
structure in terms of quarks gluons and
their interactions
these particles interacting together
make up protons and neutrons which along
with electrons in turn make up more
familiar atoms
but this creates a question
the mass of quarks inside a proton is
much less than that of the proton itself
and gluons have no mass at all
how is this possible
in order to find some answers we have to
dive into the world inside the proton
but this presents a
challenge protons are made up of chaotic
bundles of quarks and gluons moving at
near light speed interacting and
annihilating each other
it has always seemed nearly impossible
to create an accurate picture of this
world
but a new collaborative project is
visualizing the fundamental structure of
the proton based on original research
and sophisticated animation
visualization has been a powerful tool
for science for the last three decades
the hubble space telescope has produced
stunning images that have transformed
how people everywhere view the universe
now a startling new view of the
subatomic world is also within reach
physicists from mit and jefferson lab
are working with a group of animators
and documentary filmmakers to both
create a more accurate visualization of
the structure of the proton
and to document the collaboration
between science and the arts that drives
this work
the goal is to provide a more complete
view of subatomic structures that has
the potential to change how people think
about the nature of matter itself
i've created the three quarks as points
of light
and i've given them each a chromodynamic
color and i've set it up so they trade
colors between each other the whole time
they're also moving in a way where
they're jumping
around i think this was very very good
the way you did that yeah
visualization has long been used to help
explain and understand the subatomic
world
and these pictures have become more
sophisticated as our understanding has
improved
the ancient greeks believed that matter
could be split in more and more parts
until in the end what was left were the
smallest indivisible constituents or
atoms from the greek word atomos which
means indivisible
at the end of the 19th century
scientists learned that matter can be
deconstructed into molecules comprised
of atoms
however the choice of the word atom was
premature
in the 20th century we learned atoms can
be deconstructed into electrons and
their nuclei comprised of protons and
neutrons
and eventually that every proton or
neutron contains three primary quarks
that define their separate identities
often constituent parts of all matter
are portrayed as being shaped like round
billiard balls or in the case of quarks
as balls within the larger ball of a
proton
we add squiggly lines arrows and other
shapes to denote the forces at work at
the quantum scale while these diagrams
can help explain what's going on they in
no way represent the reality of what
this quantum world is actually like the
reference image that is in your slide
deck is
you know i look at that and i have no
idea what's going on in there i see
little you know balls with up arrows and
down arrows and squiggly lines
in the proton the quarks are held
together by a force where gluons are
exchanged and with such a strength that
the quarks and gluons cannot be isolated
the quarks and gluons carry a new
quantum property known as color the
theory used to describe this force is
known as quantum chromodynamics or qcd
the quantum theory of color
there are three types of quantum color
called red
blue and green in analogy to the primary
colors of visible light all observable
systems of quarks and gluons and their
associated anti-particles found in
nature
are predicted in qcd to have equal
amounts of red blue and green color
that is they are colored white in
analogy to visible light
quarks do not actually have these colors
but just as white light can be divided
into different colors so can quark
systems be divided into equal amounts of
red green and blue
when we enter the quantum world
particles that are confined to small
volumes move at near light speed
everything is in continual motion
gluons transform their energy into pairs
of virtual matter and antimatter that
are continuously created and destroyed
creating a quark c
their existence exerted on other
particles as a pressure
in this strange quantum world
conservation of energy can be
temporarily broken and even massive
matter antimatter pairs can live short
times
yet order also rules
each elementary particle has a quantum
property known as spin which behaves
like an intrinsic angular momentum
nature's rules for spin provide order to
the visible universe and is the reason
for the periodic table of the elements
and the shell structure of nuclei
to learn about the underlying structure
of matter scientists often rely on
microscopes
in a microscope light scatters from the
object of interest
the scattered light is focused detected
in the eye of the viewer and processed
in her brain
the process is non-destructive in that
the leaf or insect is not affected
with our eyes we can readily discern
structures of very large scales in the
cosmos to human size scales of a meter
down to scales of 10 microns as for
example a layer of the familiar kitchen
aluminum foil
the ratio of such aluminum foil to a
meter is down by a factor of a hundred
thousand
scaling down with another factor of a
hundred thousand gives the size of an
atom which we can see with powerful
electron microscopes
one needs to scale down with yet another
factor of a hundred thousand to come to
the size of a proton less than one
femtometer or 10 to the minus 15th
meters
to see inside matter at this tiny scale
we use electron accelerators as
microscopes
hera was a particle accelerator located
at daisy in hamburg germany operating
from 1992 to 2007.
hera was the world's first and up to now
only collider facility of electron and
proton beams and discovered that gluons
dominate deep inside a proton
jefferson lab located in newport news
virginia uses intense and polarized
electron beams to impinge on fixed
targets of protons and heavier nuclei to
make precise maps of matter in a region
where a few quarks dominate
a major new accelerator the electron ion
collider or eic is being developed in
the u.s to be located at brookhaven
national lab in long island new york and
it is anticipated to start operations in
the 2030s
eic will provide precise maps to bridge
the regions where a few quarks dominate
the structure of protons and nuclei to
where gluons dominate
the goal is to provide us with an
understanding of the internal structure
of the proton and more complex atomic
nuclei that is comparable to our
knowledge of the electron structure of
atoms which lies at the heart of modern
technologies
what if there were no gluons and quark
gluon interactions
your mass and the mass of the visible
world would drop by about an order of
magnitude
the mri technique is based on using a
high magnetic field to reverse the spins
of the protons in the body
without gluons and quark gluon
interactions the signal strength would
drop to 20 percent of its value
indeed without gluons there would be no
nucleons no atomic nuclei no visible
world
is it science fiction to believe
understanding this miraculous quark
gluon structure of nuclei can lead to
21st century applications
no
as even if the internal structure of
protons and more complex atomic nuclei
reside in a quantum world with light
speeds with ever-changing numbers or
particles
and with strong interactions
ultimate knowledge of this world will
lead to the future of modern industry
and medical applications
an example is given by modern computing
that relies on our knowledge and ability
to manipulate the quantum world
how do we learn about this strange world
with electronic accelerators
like conventional cameras how our
accelerator sees its subject is governed
by two adjustable parameters resolution
or pixel size
and shutter speed
the resolution is correlated with the
energy of the device to probe
substructures of the proton with its one
femtometer size the electron must be
moving very near light speed the
negatively charged electron interacts
with the fractionally charged quarks
inside the proton by exchanging a photon
the quantum of electricity and magnetism
this photon exchange can keep the proton
intact but more commonly smashes it in
pieces
google earth in zooming from the earth's
radius to the mit dome
increases the spatial resolution by
about a factor of a hundred thousand
the same factor we saw earlier that
successively brings us from a human
height to the thickness of household
aluminum foil
then to the size of an atom
and finally to the radius of a proton
the shutter of a camera is a door that
opens for a definite time to allow
selected light to reach the medium
this time can for our accelerator also
be determined from the electron and the
proton and can be equated with the value
of bjork and x
x can be interpreted as the fraction of
momentum of the proton that is carried
by the struck quark
mostly based on a large data set from
the only previous electron proton
collider we have accumulated snapshots
of the charged structure of the proton
taken in a special boosted reference
frame where one over x represents the
shutter speed and one over q the spatial
resolution
qcd prescribes an evolution with q
squared which connects quarks and gluons
the animation shows the quark and gluon
momentum distributions derived from
these data
note that the gluon g
and c quark s distributions are reduced
by a factor of 20 in these graphs
in a regular microscope we use light to
scatter from objects to magnify such
that we can see them with our eyes this
light does not disturb the object as we
see it as is
this is not true for our high energy
electron scattering microscope
as an artifact of the special reference
frame used for interpretation of the
scattering experiments smashing the
proton apart we have gathered knowledge
about the one-dimensional momentum
fractions of quarks and gluons inside
them we have also gathered knowledge
about the transverse spatial size of the
composite proton from elastic scattering
where the proton stays intact this is
important knowledge
but limited
due to these limitations it has been
difficult to portray the inner structure
and dynamics of the proton
but what do the data tell us
for the first time we have constructed
animations to illustrate the proton
structure as a variation with x and as a
variation with q squared
if one views deep inside the proton with
fast shutter speeds or at small values
of bjork and x
its structure is dominated by gluons
gluons split in more gluons and two
gluons can recombine into one causing
much activity or dynamics viewed with
more modest shutter speeds the process
where a gluon creates two quarks one
quark and one antiquark can be seen
such a fluctuation is the root of what
is termed a quark c
and is for example responsible for
details of the inner charge distribution
of the charge neutral neutron
viewed at slow shutter speeds or at
large bjork and x the proton structure
gets dominated by three effective blobs
which carry the valence quark identity
of the proton as being two up quarks and
one down quark confined together in a
single proton by the exchange of gluons
what do we see when we peer inside the
proton while increasing the spatial
resolution q squared of our camera
the answer depends on at which shutter
speed x we are looking
at small values of x we see more detail
appear with increasing q squared but we
also see more and more gluons appear due
to the specifics of qcd
the observer will have to distill this
information from what appears a squashed
pancake like proton due to the
relativistic effect called lorentz
contraction
at medium x we see again the details
increase and both the density of the
gluons and quark c
increase with q squared the gluons
faster
at high x we see a coarse structure
reflecting two up and one down quarks a
structure that becomes more evident at
higher q squared with also more gluons
and quark c appearing with q squared as
driven by qcd but again the squashing of
the spherical proton into the
pancake-like objects complicates the
ability of the observer to extract the
proton structure and underlying quark
gluon interactions
by varying the pixel size and the
shutter speed of our electron
accelerator camera we have gathered
information about the proton structure
over the last five decades since the
discovery of quarks and qcd we learned
about the transverse spatial size of the
composite proton and the one-dimensional
momentum fractions of quarks and gluons
inside them
however large gaps of understanding
remain
for now we have used our imagination to
fill this gap and animate what the data
tell us about the three-dimensional
structure of the matter deep inside us
but much better qcd theory developments
over the last two decades now provide
the foundation to extract these
three-dimensional pictures of the
structure from select designer electron
quark scattering processes
to accomplish this we need a microscope
with sufficient intensity to capture
these designer processes and image the
structures at the finest quark gluon
levels to charter the rapidly moving
gluon oceans quark seas and primary
quark continents
the residue of the quark gluon
interactions in individual protons and
neutrons leaks out and creates
sufficient nuclear binding to pack
protons and neutrons tightly together in
tiny atomic nuclei
these act well beyond a mere collection
of protons and neutrons and are much
more dynamic harboring mysteries as tail
tales of the underlying quark gluon
world
and vice versa the behavior of quarks
and gluons is expected to be entangled
with the structure of the nucleus they
reside in
massive computer simulations indicate
exotic gluons may be exchanged between
individual protons and neutrons
the nucleus can also act as an amplifier
and pack so many gluons together that no
more fit leading to saturation of the
interactions
for the first time we have developed a
new animation-based framework in which
to communicate understand and explore
the fundamental structure of matter for
the curious mind these first generation
animations are based on current
understanding and available data and
seek to capture essential aspects of the
strange and beautiful quantum world of
the microcosm but many mysteries remain
in how the visible matter in the
universe is constructed from elementary
constituents we now are working on a 3d
visualization of these animations
and then we'll continue our journey to
animate the nucleus
you